[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je m'appelle félicité tchibindat je suis
la représentante du ministère au niger
et je viens d'un pays où l'afrique
centrale de promo bazin on y pleut neuf
mois dans la rue et c'est en venant du
cher que j'ai pris vraiment l'essence la
résidence quand on africa development
university m'a demandé de betteraves
ficr surprise dans les thèses figra de
la glaise
enfin du thé en beauce dans les images
de sa guerre égérie la résidence parce
que comment je vais aborder cela et j'ai
cherché un peu la décision est pour moi
c'est vraiment autour des places entre
les individus et la définition qui m'a
vraiment plu est celle ci je vous la
livre une personne résidente
c'est une personne qui a la capacité de
se développer malgré la cité blanc c'est
exactement ça c'est ce que nous avons
avons entendu tout au long de ses tanks
c'est vraiment des personnes qui ont
réussi à se développer malgré
l'adversité et j'étais sur les routes
charité hier après ce nul 2 2
home est sur les routes du niger de
maradi et zinder deux acteurs paradis de
maradi à yannick laurent trilles heures
par la route à 18 heures et finalement
c'est là que j'ai rencontré les visages
et les face de la résidence aux coups de
bâton que nous avons entendues sont des
sites à la sont les gens qui vivent à
niamey qui ont des parcours qui sans
plus des parcours urbains
moi j'aimerais vous parler de ces jeunes
de ses enfants de ses fans et de saison
qui sont dans les villages dans le
terroir algérien et qui nous montre
comment elles changent le destin provins
prenant même le dessin et qu'elle change
la vie leur vie la vie de leurs familles
et de là-haut
j'ai rencontré un groupe de femmes
notre intel comme ces femmes à pratiquer
et elles ont décidé de ramasser les
ordures ménagères qui défigurent les
rues de man paradis les villages les
chante en particulier les classiques et
elles ont indiqué qu'elles ont décidé de
faire le ramassage et arrêté ses ordures
ses classiques dépendance à ces
placements être transformée pour faire
du bruit est paré pour faire des balles
pour les toilettes en quelque sorte
ruine notre vie utile à ses plastiques
qui sans vraiment dangereux pour la
santé
pas simplement la santé humaine mais
aussi la santé des animaux
elles ont aussi dit que elle veut
sensibiliser les familles à faire le
prix art à mazet a plié et à contrôler
les ordures ménagères elles sont aussi
des quelque chose elle sentit nous
allions
civiliser ces jeunes qui sont dans les
femmes qui sont dans les palais en ceux
qui connaissent le fisher et qui sont
qui rend alors lors du show mais s'ils
rentrent du thé devant un bâtiment 10
nous devons leur demander que eux aussi
ils puissent aider au ramassage des
ordures
ce sont des femmes qui ne se connaissent
pas ce que le de changement climatique
je pense qu'elle n'a entendu parler du
changement climatique ni de l'économie
verte mais par leur part leur propre
esprit d'entreprise elles ont décidé de
prendre en mer et de transformer le
paysage de maradi pour en faire une
ville propre une ville agréable ça c'est
un premier exemple qui font moins pas
comment on prend son destin en main et
ont des cibles pour des choses qui sont
positives non seulement pour elle mais
aussi pour la communauté
j'ai aussi rencontré des chefs
traditionnels contre l'entente chefs
traditionnels ont dix ans les gars de la
ces chefs traditionnels aujourd'hui en
prix à l'engagement de lutter contre les
mariages des enfants
les mariages forcés les mariages
précoces
parce que dans nos régions
les filles sans donner en mariage à 12
ans à 13 ans à 14 ans a quel sens loi 16
ans elles sont arrachés de leur enfance
de leur adolescence qui comprit de
l'école et ses chefs traditionnels ont
pris le bâton de pèlerin pour aller
parler à tous les autres pour dire que
nous devons mettre fin à cela parce que
quelqu'un ici a dit que c'est la moitié
de la population ne ne pourront pas la
ligne ne pouvons pas empêcher qu'ils
puissent 4,5 moitié pour réguler au
développement le niger de posséder ne
peut ce soir à se développer par elles
toutes et toutes les personnes
les enfants et les femmes dansaient et
ses chefs en gentil pris cet engagement
il y a des résultats
le ch est-ce que j'ai eu le temps de
beaulieu au mexique que j'ai dit j'ai
dit que personne de marc et si il ya un
mariage comme azerty et moi j'adore ce
mariage et ça fait depuis le mois de
débuts de bakassi mariage ont été amenés
et qui sont les chefs traditionnels ont
une autorité morale son époux c est peut
être des agents de changement
l'histoire de cette fatima qui était à
l'école que son père a voulu donner en
mariage avec l'avait déjà pris la dot de
50000 et c'est le chef qui a tout fait
pour que dans la nuit le mariage qu'elle
puisse continuer de repartir à l'école
et quand elle est repartie à l'école
aujourd'hui elle travaille elle
accompagne francs de salaire mensuel
elle prend en charge sa famille et son
père est venu lui demander pardon
il a dit je n'avais pas compris
marcy ouvert pour moi l'avenir de ma
fille c'était le mariage et ça ne sert à
rien aujourd'hui je suis conscient que
l'école est important portant pour pour
les filles que pour les garçons et je
suis le premier après le plaidoyer
auprès d autre part pour laisser les
enfants à l'école pour qu'elle puisse
réussi contribuer au bien-être de la
balançoire bien-être organise la vesle
on a parlé rêve ici mais aussi qu'ils
puissent contribuer au bien-être de la
famille de la pauvreté troisième exemple
c'est des femmes dans un village perdu
il ya un taux de la lumière qui est en
décidé de donner des conseils aux autres
enfin sur l'alimentation du jeune enfant
aujourd'hui nous savons que il ya eu une
période très courte
tante qui commence dans dans le ventre
les neuf mois de grossesse et les deux
ans de la première de 1re série sénile
jours ces missions sont cruciales pour
le développement de l'enfant
après c'est trop tard pour son énorme en
physique pour son développement produit
et que si on leur a si n'a pas cette
alimentation de qualité
c'est en juillet aura des conséquences
irréversibles sur son développement
cérébral ses fans pensaient les
autrement donner une alimentation de
qualité avec les moyens qu'elles sont
dans les villages ces femmes vous ne
connaissez peut-être pas et sont en
train de préparer le futur du niger
parce que c'est parce qu'aussi en rater
une jour en a reperdu partie des
potentialités
elles sont en train de préserver les
potentialités pour les générations
futures et mons et c'est un peu ce
message que je voulais faire passer que
dans mon voyage de nos matinées rang
j'ai rencontré les hauts des bas les
jeunes qui sont en train d'écrire le
choix de la puissance l'épargné c'est la
giralda loi qui a mis la sciatique unis
c'est un film assez fragile que
l'histoire est là
de ses créations ses jeunes ses fans ses
sens en train de transformer de marée
déclaratif qui est différent qui n'est
par le narratif de la misère de la
dépendance elle la ratifie est positif
et c'est pour moi un véritable honneur
et je suis fier de les avoir rencontrés
la revue de relance l'espoir d'avoir vu
dans leurs yeux la résidence et c'est ça
qui me permets moi de faire un travail
qui me permets moi de dire oui il ya de
l'espoir c'est et ce point se trouve là
bas qui a une histoire transformation à
quelque chose qui se passe en ce moment
c'est dans ces villages là et que c'est
ça que de penser les vrais mondes
devancer
ordinaires ces femmes anti ma saison
gentiment devant les célébrer parce que
elles sont en train de changer en
profondeur dans les terroirs
c'est important parce que l'histoire
prend ses racines dans les terroirs si
nous voulons que c'est là que tout part
la résidence on a parlé de l'arbre du
désert il faut que les racines soient
fortes et ses racines se trouvent dans
l'ansé terroir avec ses fins devant
célébrer ce qu'elles font
parce que bien souvent elles montrent
que malgré l'adversité on peut s'en
sortir alors que avant des femmes qui
préfèrent est gelée fut aussi affamé
l'enfant donner des laxatifs pour que
les enfants entrent dans le programme
dix ans qu'elle est et de l'aide
alimentaire et les 500 impressionnait
les autres manquent qu'elle se prenne en
main qu'elle se mêle et qu'elles sont en
train de changer au gré sont arabes de
pouvoir garder leur enfant en france
rend votre santé et de montrer de tout
commence pas soin et changement c'est ça
commence par soi même et cesser au moins
deux messages le plus important en la
vue un peu tendu on habite ici dans la
gym une ville est jamais qu un seul
tranquille si la fusion des romans
l'adversité
le plus important c'est de se relever et
le pentu et d'avoir toujours de l'espoir
et de montrer aux autres même si ce
board pour que strata et que vous allez
y arriver pour fête des plantes y aller
et
vous savez que de les chercher l
apprentissage y a pas d'échelle ou ce
que nous faisons dans l'apprentissage
mon histoire personnelle dit aussi j'ai
vécu des expériences difficiles mais je
suis moche en plus du tout et je dis que
quand je regarde ces expériences
dimanche arc et à le mettre devant
debout devant stick pour dire que le
changement
il est déjà là et il est avec ces jeunes
cette fin ces enfants dans le terroir et
chérien que je soutiens les avoir
[Applaudissements]